[Musique]
propulsé par un combustible miracle le
cosmo gaulle 999 extrait de l'atmosphère
la fusée des jbe va partir pour la terre
sur la planète shadoks les shadoks
essaie de construire une fusée
interplanétaire mais ils sont en retard
sur leurs programmes et le professeur
shadow qu est inquiet il observe les
progrès de la fusée jbe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques temps après de chez les jib il
usine à cosmo goal subitement saft la
teneur en co selon goal tombe
mystérieusement assez au parc elle
scélérate ans jean-marc château compte
il anéantit les réserves de cosmo goal
et réduit la fusée bibi l'impuissance
[Musique]